never have I ever put oh my god never
have ever put a minute hi I'm kelcie
foods okay
and I'm Troy Brady and today we're
playing never have I ever I'm a youtuber
I have a show on BuzzFeed multiplayer I
stream on Twitch a cosplayer kind of
like all different kind of nerdy
cultural things I'm the biggest fan of
Kelsey oh I'm a speedster what can I say
hey I'm Skye and I have a YouTube
channel called skylight or I explore the
world of wellness and try all sorts of
emerging health and wellness trends and
topics I'm Emily I have a brand new
channel called mini-moon i make poetry
films and content about feminism and
women empowerment and mindfulness and
mental health and all kinds of fun stuff
ready to place questions and I'm already
like blood is boiling I my heart races
pumping never have I ever taken a sexy
selfie yeah obviously every selfie I
think you're right I'm not going on
don't take a very normal one right now
and we still are cause see that's I feel
like a little bit only reason why I
still use snapchat
[Laughter]
I'll trust anyone never have I ever sent
a dirty text to the wrong person
Oh lovely I have no
yeah that that is like one of my biggest
fears I said text to the wrong yeah but
not a dirty one the wrong person
luckily I haven't I've sent a lot of
text that should have gone to someone
else to the wrong say I almost have so I
have and I got nervous once when I was
younger I thought that I accidentally
sent some some freakish took my sister
by actually art stop and I was like okay
good I didn't send it buddy I think
because yeah it would have been some
awkward Thanksgiving stuff never have I
ever shaved my partner's pubic hair no
no that's right Java lion I hopefully
that never happens in my life I hope
that never occurs like you you do that
yourself I don't think I don't know like
it says that is if it's something that
people like want to do I don't know if
she ever needed help I would but never
have I ever kissed a celebrity I have
not yeah I would say probably not
but no and one time I did I did dance
with Michael B Jordan it was probably
the highlight of my life
no but do other youtubers count how they
go over to count okay so let's say these
questions I don't even know what needs
mean like what is this next one time it
meets tossing a salad I haven't ever
touch this hospice at what does that
mean I don't know what that basically a
booty hole I like pista but I've never
liked not all these questions are really
raunchy oh my god
not really good first thing not for me
never have I ever had to fake it you
know there's been some times here just
like it's not into this I just got a
Scott just got up
let me let this and that was a bad
sexual experience right there so yeah
[Laughter]
yeah yeah
like guys suck okay let's just like get
this over yeah and it's not because I
feel like if we were both dudes actually
this question be like no yeah I feel
like we both are just taking a deep
breath right now to decompress from that
yeah definitely processor you know what
life is life we're all humans I've done
some things that maybe I was embarrassed
by at some point but I'm over it yeah no
I'm just gonna own up to my life I was
very nervous when I saw the question she
now I'm like still kind of Oh giggling
or what so I don't know I I feel good to
have let let my demons out I guess you
know what the truth is yeah the
Internet's gonna see me a little
different